[Música]
muy buenas tardes esto es evolución no
yo sino el hecho de que hoy muchas
mujeres estemos participando en un acto
público y estemos transmitiendo
nuestras ideas comunicando nuestros
sentimientos hace 100 años era
prácticamente imposible imaginar que una
mujer hiciese lo que hoy hemos hecho
muchas que hemos pasado por este
escenario y además el hecho de que esas
mujeres tomen la palabra ha sido la
fuerza de trabajo de trabajar por la
evolución de crear evolución de provocar
evolución y de impulsar la evolución tan
profundo ha sido el cambio tan rápido ha
sido el cambio que solo 100 años hemos
conseguido derechos que se nos habían
negado a lo largo de toda la historia
que yo me atrevería a decir que en el
ámbito de la igualdad no hablamos de
evolución
hablamos de revolución de la revolución
más importante junto con la tecnológica
que se ha producido a lo largo
pensad como nos sorprendemos a veces
cuando vemos a las personas mayores que
nacieron en una sociedad en ande no
había televisión como chatean desde sus
tablets pues esas mismas personas
nacieron en una sociedad en donde las
mujeres no teníamos derecho al voto y
sin embargo están eligiendo a sus
alcaldesas a diputadas a senadoras a
presidentas esa es la verdadera
revolución pero no nació ni cayó del
cielo fíjense bien hace 3000 años
homero en la odisea plasmó la primera
vez el primer documento gráfico que
tenemos en donde un hombre mandó callar
a una mujer donde se silencio la voz de
la mujer fue en el transcurso de una
discusión entre telémaco el hijo de
ulises y su madre penélope y él le dijo
lo que aparece aquí madre cállate y
dedícate a la rueca al telar a las
labores propias del hogar porque el
relato es mío y el gobierno de esta casa
y desde entonces han pasado siglos
siglos de silencio siglos en donde la
mujer ha ocupado un segundo plano en
donde hemos asumido con naturalidad
aquello que detrás de un gran hombre
siempre hay una gran mujer siglos en
donde para poner en valor a un hombre
decíamos qué gran líder es ese hombre y
para destacar a una mujer
señalábamos su discreción su prudencia
afortunadamente esto ya ha cambiado ha
cambiado en la sociedad y sobre todo ha
cambiado en nuestras reyes las leyes han
evolucionado en el día de hoy a día de
hoy la constitución del año 1978 la que
ahora celebramos 40 y su 40 aniversario
dice que hombres y mujeres siendo
distintos tenemos garantizados los
mismos derechos las mismas obligaciones
las mismas libertades y el acceso a las
mismas oportunidades y aquí es donde
viene mi primera reflexión y aquí es
donde os dejo mi primera pregunta hemos
conseguido
la evolución que se ha producido en las
leyes la hayamos trasladado a la vida
real de las mujeres y de los hombres en
españa' creo que en algunos ámbitos si
en el ámbito formativo estamos en una
universidad hay más mujeres que terminan
carreras universitarias que hombre el
año pasado seis de cada diez incluso
obtenemos mejores calificaciones
académicas en el curso anterior
las mujeres aprobaron el 82 por ciento
de los créditos en los que se
matricularon los hombres 10 puntos menos
por lo tanto hemos conseguido la
igualdad hemos evolucionado en igualdad
en la formación después pueda accedemos
al mercado laboral y yo me atrevería a
decir que en el primer empleo sí que
accedemos en condiciones de igualdad y
que también hemos evolucionado nacíamos
y salíamos de muy atrás y a día de hoy
la casa de actividad femenina es sólo 11
puntos más bajo que la masculina y
además de eso las mujeres accedemos en
mayor medida a la función pública pero
la tercera fase de nuestra vida tiene
que ver con crecer dentro de nuestro
ámbito profesional
promocionar dentro de nuestro empleo y
es aquí donde por desgracia empiezan los
problemas en el año 1982 se utilizó una
imagen que veremos a continuación para
hablar de la situación de las mujeres y
de los hombres y por desgracia hoy 2018
podemos utilizar la misma imagen y que
refleja perfectamente qué es lo que
ocurre cuando una mujer y un hombre
quieren promocionar esta imagen hacía
referencia a fred astaire ginger rogers
los dones eran magníficos bailarines
pero en lo que se decía es que fred
astaire bailaba fenomenal ginger rogers
bailaba igual de bien que él pero ella
lo hacía hasta atrás y con tacones altos
los tacones altos de las mujeres de la
sociedad actual son que dedican tres
horas más al trabajo en casa que los
hombres es que el 96 por ciento de las
excedencias para cuidar a mayo a mayores
y a niños son solicitadas por mujeres
es que un tercio de las mujeres que
trabajan fuera de casa tienen un
contrato que les permite trabajar a
media jornada y eso tiene unas
consecuencias tremendas la principal de
ellas es la que muchas imagináis y que
estáis pensando en este momento y es que
aquel chico que entró contigo en la
empresa ha seguido creciendo dentro de
ella y que sin embargo tú estás
exactamente exactamente en el mismo
lugar que cuando te quedaste embarazada
y digo bien embarazada porque igual que
decía el otro día y es algo que comparto
que lo decía hace unos meses
anna botín la presidenta del banco de
santander la maternidad está penalizadas
en la sociedad española actual hay un
estudio que nos indica cómo que cuando
un hombre es padre su renta crece y
cuando una mujer es madre su renta
disminuye y que con el paso de los años
es muy muy complicado que vuelva a
alcanzar los mismos niveles es aquí
donde tenemos que trabajar porque es
tremendamente
y no se lo puede permitir la sociedad
pero desde luego es tremendamente
injusto para las mujeres que tienen que
renunciar a su desarrollo profesional oa
tener hijos qué situación nos queda pues
que en la sociedad española actual
tenemos una tasa de natalidad de una de
las más bajas de la unión europea y
dentro de unos años sólo el 33 por
ciento de la población está en edad de
trabajar necesitamos evolucionar
necesitamos ir de la conciliación
evolucionar hacia la corresponsabilidad
no queremos quitarle derecho a los
hombres
queremos que hombres y mujeres tengamos
y disfrutemos de los mismos derechos y
que también renunciemos a lo mismo para
desarrollarnos plenamente desde el punto
de vista profesional y desde el punto de
vista personal quiero trasladaros dos
últimas reflexiones en materia de
evolución la primera de ellas pensáis
que podemos de hablar hablar de
evolución en materia de igualdad cuando
escasos kilómetros de distancia seguro
que hay mujeres que nos están siguiendo
en este momento en redes sociales son
obligadas a casarse a través de
matrimonios forzosos sufren la
mutilación genital femenina son víctimas
de trata de mujeres con fines de
explotación sexual es tremendamente
injusto y creo que sería una frivolidad
que a día de hoy hablaremos de evolución
en igualdad cuando estas mujeres están
sufriendo esa terrible lacra no hablemos
de igualdad de evolución en igualdad y
miremos les y a la cara están nadie
malal a una niña que era paquistaní y
que los talibanes no la dejaban ir al
colegio no le permitían formarse ni a
ella ni al resto de niñas ella se empeñó
su familia al apoyo y sufrió un atentado
y como consecuencia de ese atentado su
voz se oyó más y hoy es un referente
para millones de hombres y mujeres en el
mundo y premio nobel de la paz en el año
después llegó otra mujer nadia murat con
21 años fue secuestrada vio cómo
asesinaban a sus hermanos el estado
islámico y cómo mataban a su madre y
ella y cientos de mujeres de su ciudad
fueron violadas ella es hoy la voz del
genocida genocidio yihad y es importante
y le han reconocido también como premio
nobel en el año 2018
josh trasladó una pregunta cuántas nadie
as cuantas malas hay en el mundo a las
que tenemos que mirar a la cara y
ayudarles para que la evolución en
igualdad también llegue a sus vidas y la
última reflexión que quiero haceros esta
tarde y que os traslado también para que
la tengáis muy presente antes hemos
hablado de evolución en tecnología y
prácticamente es muy difícil que se
puedan dar pasos atrás cuando hablamos
de evolución tecnológica pero en materia
de derechos es distinto en materia de
derechos evolución en derechos podemos
involucionar podemos perder los derechos
que ya hemos conseguido y eso es un
retroceso que no podemos permitir
hay una imagen está irán irán en el año
1970 irán en la actualidad es importante
que valoremos las cotas de igualdad que
hemos conseguido para no perderlas los
derechos no caen del cielo los derechos
se trabajan los derechos se luchan y
para eso necesitamos a mujeres pero
necesitamos también a hombres la lucha
por la igualdad no es un trabajo solo de
mujeres sino que tiene que ser un
objetivo común de toda la sociedad
terminó con una cita con la cita de
stephanes by que dijo que el milagro de
ayer es la evidencia de hoy pues hagamos
que la igualdad deje de ser un milagro
en la vida de la sociedad española y del
resto de mujeres del mundo y se
convierta en una verdadera evidencia y
realidad para hacer una sociedad mucho
más justa y para que los españoles
vivamos también mucho más felices y el
resto de hombres y mujeres del mundo
creo sinceramente que nos lo debemos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]